[Music]
if people are impeding your development
you sacrifice your relationship with
them it's a very very rough rule
let's say you're miserable and unhappy
okay here's a cure
find what's valuable and
Let It Go
so we could say well maybe it's a
relationship that you have maybe it's a
relationship with your parents right and
the relationship is pathological but
you're locked into it you value it and
no wonder because it's a relationship
with your parents and you're suffering
terribly because of it
what do you do maybe you let it go it's
a sacrifice and the idea is that well
that'll clear the future for you well
very frequently when people are
suffering terribly not always because
sometimes you just suffer stupidly
blindly and without recourse you know
you get cancer and then you die so we
have no idea how to deal with that but
sometimes the reason that you're
suffering is because you just won't let
go of the thing that's biting you and
I've had clients like this I can't stop
communicating with my mother who phones
me three times a day every day of my
life it never says anything that isn't
unbelievably critical and demeaning I
can't let that go that's not such a good
idea the funny thing too often when
people let something like that go it
goes away sorts itself out and then
comes back so they don't even end up
losing it but unless they're willing to
let it go to sacrifice it they make no
Headway whatsoever
and I'm not saying I'm a great man but
I'm telling you this hero
I ain't what I was you might not think
all that much of me
but you would if you knew what I was
though if you'd have saw me when I had a
severe stuttering problem and I couldn't
talk outside my house
you would think much of me if you saw me
when I flunked out of school
I'm on my third marriage you would think
a whole lot more of me if you knew me
when I was living in that car for three
years because see what I what he turned
me into was something I never thought I
didn't think I'd ever be this
people come to me from everywhere I meet
with kings and queens
I was in Botswana with the president and
the first lady of Botswana then I met
the the Crown Prince of Abu Dhabi he
came out of his chair at the race to
come meet me you know I came to meet me
just simply because of my gift
I make people laugh it put me in the
presence of Great Men that's what my
gift has done for me that's what your
gift will do for you that scripture is
talking about you
look man
identify that god-giving gift and get to
pursuing it maybe you here cause you
need to hear this here maybe you hear me
maybe you need to explore your
imagination maybe you just need to
identify your gift so you can quit
tripping in your own life trying to
figure out what you can do
there is a statement I think it was
Pascal he said you know all of man's
problems arise because he cannot sit by
himself in a room for 30 minutes alone
and it's very true I always needed to be
stimulated and when the iPhone came
along Odom was dead I would never be
bored again even if I'm standing in line
I'm on my iPhone and I thought it was
great and when I was a kid I used to try
and overclock my brain be like how many
thoughts can I think at once the answer
is only one but I would try to like
think multiple thoughts at once and I
was proud of that I was proud that my
brain was always running this engine was
always moving and it's a disease it's
actually the road to misery and now that
I'm older I realize like you actually
want to again rest your mind you want to
learn how to settle into your mind now I
look forward to solitary confinement you
leave me alone for a day it'll be like
the happiest day I've had in a while and
and that is a superpower that I think
everybody can attain
the superpower of learning to be alone
and enjoying it yeah as much as you want
people to agree and you want the people
around you to be supporting your dreams
and all it's not going to be like that
all the time you got to do it alone and
people will help you and when you when
you get the ball rolling people will
jump on but if you don't believe nobody
else is going to believe people come
along because your belief is so insane
that your belief is so strong that makes
people be like yo this crazy following
your dreams
is a lonely solitary scary dangerous
Pursuit you can't wait for somebody to
think you can do it because they don't
think you can do nothing they can't do
it's a lonely scary dangerous Pursuit
and you got to be willing to risk
everything to become that seed of what
you believe it's in there you gotta be
Fearless you got to be relentless
you have lots of reasons to be God
there's reasons to be resentful about
your existence everyone you know is
gonna die you know you too and there's
going to be a fair bit of pain along the
way and lots of it's going to be unfair
it's like yeah no wonder you're
resentful it's like act it out and see
what happens you make everything you're
complaining about infinitely worse
there's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad it is some stupid son of
a like you could figure out a way
to make it a lot worse
so you think well what do you do about
that well you accept it that's what life
is like it's suffering that's what the
religious people have always said life
is suffering yes well who wants to admit
that well just think about it well so
what do you do in the face of that
suffering
try to reduce it
start with yourself what good are you
get yourself together for Christ's sake
so that when your father dies you're not
winding away in a corner and you can
help plan the funeral and you can stand
up solidly so that people can rely on
you that's better it'll be a damn victim
of course you're a victim put yourself
together and then maybe if you put
yourself together you know how to do
that you know what's wrong with you if
you'll admit it you know there's a few
things you could like polish up a little
bit that you might even be able to
manage in your insufficient present
condition and so you might shine
yourself up a little bit and then your
eyes will be a little more open then you
can shine yourself up a little bit more
and then maybe you could bring your
family together instead of having them
be the hateful spiteful neurotic
infighting bats that you're like doomed
to spend Christmas with
so when you fix yourself up a little bit
kind of humbly because you know God
you're a fixer-upper if there ever was
one and then you gotta figure out well
can you figure out how to make peace
with your Idiot Brother and probably not
because he's just as dumb as you so how
the hell are you gonna manage that and
so then you've maybe you get somewhere
that way and your family's sort of
functioning and you find out well that
kind of relieved a little bit of
suffering although it reduced the
opportunities for spiteful revenge and
that's kind of a pain in the neck and so
then you get your family together a
little bit and you're a little clued in
then at least a bit because you've done
something difficult that's actually
difficult you're a little wiser and so
then maybe you could put a tentative
finger out beyond the family and try to
change some little thing without
wrecking it it's like our society is
complex and we teach our students that
they could just fix it it's like go fix
a military helicopter and see how far
you get with that it's like you're going
to get a dude you're like a chimp with a
wrench whack oh look it's better it's
like no it's not better things are
complicated and to fix things is really
hard and you have to be like a golden
tool to fix things and you're not and
that's the other message of the West
it's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life
and I'm not saying it's only the message
of the West
how do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person
that's how you do it well that's hard
it takes responsibility and I think you
know if you said to someone you want to
have a meaningful life
everything you do matters that's the
definition of a meaningful life but
everything you do matters
you're gonna have to carry that with you
I get you know worried sometimes I get
these feelings and so what I decided to
do was create a 90 second rule for
myself where I would end suffering as it
arises because anybody tells you an Anne
suffer is full of crap the reason is
your brain is a two million year old
brain it's not designed to make you
happy it's designed to make you survive
but there's no saber-toothed tiger for
you to react to anymore so now we worry
about what are people thinking about us
do I have enough money over the last two
years what I've done is play this little
90-second Rule and if I feel tension in
me I go okay that's suffering where's it
coming what am I stressed about what are
they concerned about and what I
immediately do is I realize
the stressful thought what I really do
now is I dig in and I notice that the
only time you have stress or suffer is
when you believe a stressful thought